Oh
everyone welcome to this live session of
your daily equation that is good to see
all of you it's 3 p.m. here on the east
coast of the United States and a very
cloudy day here in in upstate New York
where I am at the moment and I'm looking
forward to spending an hour with you
guys hanging out talking about whatever
is on your mind and answering a few
questions
arguing with you a little bit if you
want to push back on anything that I say
that that you don't agree with I'm all
too happy to have that kind of an
argument just put your comments in the
chat some of you have already asked some
questions on Twitter and YouTube I've
got those so let me just jump right in
right now and begin with the first
question I'll pick one at random from
the list that I see over here and okay
Bonnie L asks in the chat hi professor
Greene
why does gravity go away in freefall and
that that is a deep question it's a
question that
people didn't fully realize the answer
to that question until Albert Einstein
came along in the early part of the 20th
century and I'm going to discuss the
general theory of relativity gravity the
relationship between gravity and
acceleration the relationship between
gravity and curvature I'm gonna start
that I don't know sometime next week is
my guess when I'll get into that but to
answer Bonnie's question here's here's
the idea so I'll give it in the
historical version so Einstein was
sitting in the Patent Office in Bern
Switzerland this is about 1907 and he
has what he later in life described as
the happiest thought of his entire life
what is the happiest thought in Albert
Einstein's entire life in the Patent
Office he imagines that there's a
painter who is painting a building and
therefore he's high up on the ladder and
Einstein envisions the painter falling
off of the ladder and Einstein imagines
what the painter feels as he or she is
falling downward and the key insight
that Einstein has is that the painter
will not feel their own weight during
the descent and I like to phrase that I
mean if you imagine that the painter is
standing on a scale and the scale is
like velcroed to the soles of the shoes
of the painter as the painter is falling
imagine the painter falling feet first
the painter and the scale they fall at
the same rate that is the deep inside
and that comes right from Isaac Newton's
description of gravity where the force
of gravity is proportional to the mass
of the object but the relationship
between force and mass force equals mass
times acceleration means that the mass
dependence on the gravitational side and
the mass dependence on the acceleration
side they cancel each other out this is
this idea that inertial and
gravitational mass are the same put in
those details to the side intuitively
because of the
the painter and the scale they fall at
the same rate which means the painter
can't press down on the scale any longer
which means if the painter looks down at
the reading of the scale the painter
will find that the reading of the scale
drops to zero because the painter is no
longer pressing down on the surface of
the scale so that's the sense if when
your are unfree fall the sense of your
own weight goes away and and that's
basically the idea that in a sense
gravity is going away gravity is the
sensation that you have I mean right now
I feel gravity because my body wants to
fall downward under the pull of the
Earth's gravity but my chair is getting
in the way so I feel that force pressing
up on the seat if I was in freefall
however I wouldn't feel that force I
wouldn't be able to press down on the
scale in that sense my weight would go
to zero and therefore in that sense grab
it would go away
my favorite demonstration of this and
I'm think I'm gonna do this for you all
next week it's it's so simple you take a
bottle of water I don't I do have one
around here but I can't actually do the
experiment if I were to take this bottle
of water and poke holes in it we all
know the water would spray out of the
holes but the beautiful thing and I'll
show you this next week is I then let
the bottle go into freefall the water
stops spraying out of the holes why the
water sprays out initially because the
water feels the force of gravity that
gravity pulls the water out of the holes
of the bottle but when I let the bottle
go in freefall the water inside no
longer feels its own weight like the
painter in freefall if the water doesn't
feel its own weight there's nothing
pulling the water out of the holes the
water stops spraying and indeed that's
exactly what does happen all right so
that's a nice introduction to things
that we're going to talk about next week
general theory of relativity gravity and
all that kind of good stuff but let's
now move on from there and what do we
know there's a whole little discussion I
see between a variety of people lived
with von Beethoven and others
pry out - on freewill others have chimed
in to this idea as well so the question
that is being asked is when we consider
the fact that universe is so random and
vast it's more likely that free will
does not exist if if Yashraj chimes in
prior gasps what exactly is freewill and
then I see further down the line that
people are noting that at least from the
perspective of how I described it in in
my latest book and as I've described in
various other places the absence of
freewill emerges from the recognition
that every thought you have every
decision you make every action that you
undertake at a microscopic level is
nothing but your particles moving one
way or another and the motion of your
particles or more precisely the quantum
mechanical evolution of the state of
your particles is fully governed by
mathematical law mathematical decree
there simply is no opportunity for you
to get in on the action and somehow
change the mathematical unfolding so if
you're not making those decisions
because you are not in charge of the
motion of your particles what is making
those decisions and the answer is the
mathematics underlying the fundamental
laws of physics whatever that
mathematics might be so then I see
somebody else chiming in and saying but
how then can you explain that people
have a sensation of freewill why is it
feels so real in the answer to that is
quite straightforward
there are many sensations we have that
are not truly reflecting how nature is
constructed I mean you know right now
I'm sitting at a table right here can
you hear it I'm knocking on the table
the table is made of wood this wood this
table feels like it is completely solid
but you all know that that sensation
that I have of sitting at a solid table
is misleading because the true nature of
the quanta
world establishes that the vast majority
of this table is actually empty space
it's just that my knuckles have outer
electrons that slam into the outer
electrons in the atoms and molecules
making up the table and they repel each
other and that repelling force is what I
feel and I try to push my hand through
the table so indeed I'm unable to push
my hand through the table but it's not
because the table is solid it's because
of the way particles interact and indeed
most of the table is empty space from
the standpoint of a kind of classical
version of particles making up the
ingredients in the world around us so
there you have a nice little example
where intuition is a misleading guide to
the true nature of the world and I have
to say the same thing about our
intuition that we have free will it
feels real the sensation is a real
sensation that all of us have and
presumably we have it because it has
evolutionary value presumably our
forebears in the African savanna those
that had a sensation that they were it
controlled that they had freedom of will
they perhaps are the ones that were
better able to cope with the challenges
in the world around them and therefore
those who had the tendency to envision
that they had free will are the ones
that typically would have greater
numbers of progeny thereby ceding future
generations with that very same
proclivity to imagine that they have a
freedom of the will even though that
freedom of the will is not something
that truly describes the nature of the
world and that's my view on these ideas
I'm happy for you guys to argue back if
you don't agree with that as I said I
love that back and forth so I'll wait to
see if anybody has anything further to
say on it but let me now jump over to a
question that comes to us from YouTube
it's Petri vivillon on sorry guys I feel
so bad as I dismember your names hello
from Helsinki Finland can you explain
the idea of loot quantum theory please
what is your personal opinion about it
um well Petri III can basically let me
just quickly say what is what is loop
quantum gravity trying to accomplish
it's trying to accomplish the very same
thing that string theory is attempting
to accomplish which is to blend to meld
together our understanding of quantum
mechanics the laws of physics that
manifest most strongly in the
microscopic realm with the laws of
gravity laws of this general theory of
relativity that manifests most
abundantly in the realm of big things
like stars and galaxies and look this is
a puzzle to blend these two theories
that we have been seeking to resolve for
a very very long time and a number of
proposals have been put forward
string theory this idea that the world
is fundamentally made of filaments of
energy that vibrate in different
patterns and so forth that theory is the
one that I and other strength ears have
been working on and developing on on
paper we believe that it does achieve
the goal of putting gravity and quantum
mechanics together the challenge is that
we don't know if it's the right theory
of the world we haven't been able to
experimentally test it or confirm it
through observations and therefore
there's room ample room for other
approaches to putting gravity and
quantum mechanics together and loop
quantum gravity is is one such approach
the approach that is taken to loop
quantum gravity is to really focus on
Einstein's general theory of relativity
to rewrite that theory in a slightly
different form then Einstein wrote it
down a form that
I think if Einstein were alive today he
would obviously understand it but he
would need the loop quantum gravity
community to explain to Einstein what it
is that they're doing
why this if they're writing his beloved
theory in this unusual-looking form and
in that unusual-looking form it turns
out that the means by which we quantize
theories that is the means by which we
go from a classical description of the
world to a quantum mechanical
description is easier in this these new
variables as are called this new
approach to writing done Einstein's
theory and so that community believes
that they have put gravity and quantum
mechanics together by starting with
Einstein's theory rewriting it in this
more useful form and applying the fairly
standard rules of quantization that
anybody in college you know sophomore
learns about from a string theory
standpoint we started in some sense of
the more particle physics side of things
we don't start with Einstein's general
theory of relativity we start with a
motion of these little tiny filaments
which are meant to be the way in which
we think about particles in this new
string theoretic description and what we
find amazingly is that the equations of
string theory naturally yield the
equations of the general theory of
relativity we don't start with general
relativity the loop quantum theory
people do and so we like to say that if
you were to imagine a history of science
on another planet where for some reason
those scientists first came up with
string theory before the general theory
of relativity those scientists would
have been able to extract the general
theory of relativity from their
understanding of string theory so it's
as if the loop quantum gravity people
start on this end of the story with the
general theory of relativity
string theory folks start on this other
end more from a particle physics more if
you will quantum mechanical description
of the world and we each go forward
trying to blend the other theory into
the story now do these two approaches
miss each other do they go and
completely oblique directions do they
meet in the middle these are questions
that at the moe
we can't address but I'm glad that their
different approaches that people are
taking to put gravity and quantum
mechanics together alright so what do we
have over here on the live chat from
YouTube
hey mister Brian can a particle really
go back in space or is that a
misconception really go back in space
not sure what that means I'm sure I mean
particles can go any direction space
maybe the question is can a particle go
back in time and for that I know that
there are many descriptions out there in
the wider world in which quantum
mechanics is described in terms of sort
of particles going forward in time anti
particles going backward in time it's a
useful way of thinking about quantum
mechanics for some applications but I
consider it kind of deeply misleading at
a more 30,000 foot level even in
standard quantum mechanics things are
really evolving in one temporal
direction it's not as though there's
time-travel embedded in the quantum
mechanical laws of nature rather when we
want to talk about traveling to the past
we have to introduce much more exotic
ingredients many more things that we
don't even know if they're realized in
the world things like wormholes things
like the ability to pass through
wormhole things like the ability to grab
holder the openings of a wormhole move
them relative to each other
take one opening put in near the edge of
a black hole I mean it's fairly exotic
stuff when we try to talk about things
going backward in time and most of us
are far from convinced that this kind of
backward time travel is possible indeed
most of us feel that when we understand
physics better traveling to the Past
will likely be ruled out but the door in
some sense is still open all right so I
seem to always do this I have a real
nice question I'm about to address I
touch the scroll here and then it
rapidly Scrolls by and I miss it so
sorry there was one on entanglement if
anyone wants to ask that question again
about entanglement and faster than the
speed of light I'd be happy to address
it just answer it one more time not
answer ask it one more time
what else do we have here let's see what
we'll then so roof at the Mathemagician
asks what will the next major discovery
be in physics and well it depends on
what you're asking at what lovely are
asking that question there's a lot of
exciting work happening gravitational
wave physics right now and we have long
since realized that every time we
develop a new means of examining the
wider cosmos we learn new stuff and so
in the last couple of years we've
developed finally it's been 50 years in
the making this ability to examine the
cosmos not with light waves but with
gravitational waves and with
gravitational waves you access the wider
reality in a new way and already people
are learning things about
nucleosynthesis where complex atoms come
from collisions between neutron stars is
a approach that really has gained
currency through the observations made
with gravitational wave of observatories
but there's a that's just the tip of the
iceberg we're gonna be having all sorts
of breakthroughs coming from
gravitational wave physics in the next
two years next decade so that's
certainly an incredibly exciting arena
but if you're asking the question at a
more global level
what next breakthrough do I feel we
really need in order to make that leap
to the next big understanding of the
universe my guess is that it's a deeper
understanding regarding what space and
time actually are you may be familiar
from my books are from other YouTube
videos your own studies that you know
ever since Einstein we have learned so
much about the phenomenon that can occur
within space and time and equalities
that space and time have that are not
intuitive the fact that time slows down
for an object in motion the fact that
length contracts along the direction of
motion the fact that time is warped near
a gravitational body and that warpage
can become quite sick
sniff again near a strong source of
gravity like a black hole I mean all of
these things are are wild they're
wonderful insights but none of them give
us any understanding of what space is
what time is right we think about space
as the arena within which events take
place we consider time the variable that
allows events to occur not
simultaneously that they can spread out
along this other axis the temporal
coordinate but fundamentally could it be
that space is made of ingredients like
molecules of space just like material
objects are made of collections of
molecules could time itself be made of
atoms or molecules of time and what
would those atoms and molecules of time
be like what are they about
I think these are the kinds of questions
that will need to be answered to really
ignite the next revolution and our
understanding of fundamental physics all
right what do we have here nihilistic
bro asks professor doesn't quantum
mechanics allow free will can't then our
consciousness and free will be a product
of the quantum nature of physical laws
and it's it's a natural way of retorting
against my argument that we don't have
the free will that we think that we do
so nihilistic bro I know exactly where
you're coming from but the answer that I
have is that I do not think that quantum
mechanics helps at all quantum mechanics
certainly changes our understanding of
how the universe unfolds in a classical
description the universe unfolds in a
deterministic manner in the sense that
if you tell me how things are today the
laws tell you precisely how they will be
tomorrow and that would seem to rule out
free will immediately right if you tell
me how things were before I was born
and that data is enough to determine
what's gonna happen tomorrow then what
freedom do I have if that future is
fully determined by the past together
with the fundamental laws of
cosmological unfolding quantum mechanics
comes along and this is where nihilistic
Broz intuition I believe is coming from
quantum mechanic comes along and injects
an element of happenstance an element of
probability in the unfolding so that if
you tell me how things are today the
best I can do is predict the probability
of how they will be tomorrow 30% chance
this way 20% chance that way 50% chance
another way still and so within that
probabilistic description the natural
thought is maybe freewill chooses which
outcome actually happens tomorrow maybe
the laws of physics just give us a menu
of possibilities and then it's up to
human freedom to choose which outcome
actually happens and based on our
current understanding of quantum
mechanics that is simply a wrong
description of how the universe unfolds
the outcome is a random choice that
occurs in a manner that we've yet to
fully nail down but the data that we
have from observation experiment shows
us that the outcome of a given quantum
mechanical experiment is random it's not
chosen
we can't volitionally choose the outcome
because if we did the data would not
show the random quality that it does and
randomness is not what we mean by
freedom if I told you that your choices
were determined not by a classical
Newtonian progression but by somebody
behind your back flipping a coin and
based on the random outcome of that coin
flip you make one decision or another if
that is what's going on I think that you
would agree that violates your intuition
of the freedom that you think you have
randomness is not freedom and therefore
quantum mechanics does not help us at
all in fact I'd like to say it the
following way
if you believe and I certainly do but if
you believe that the universe unfolds in
a lawful manner I don't care what the
laws are but if you agree that all you
need to know to determine how the
universe unfolds is that there's a
lawful progression from today to
tomorrow determined by laws of physics
that we may not even have in our
possession then there's no opportunity
for free will there's no place for you
to get in on the action because the laws
determine in the sense even a
probabilistic sense the laws are what
reality relies upon for the future
unfolding based upon the conditions in
the past and that's all there is to it
and therefore there's no opportunity for
free will to get in on the progression
so that's what I have to say in that
subject again if you want to argue back
please please do but let's see what else
we have here
oh so oh please stop scrolling I'm good
okay summon Amanda asks isn't wait
Amanda you just retracted your message
why it was a pretty good question him
and and I remember what it says so I'm
gonna ask
Amanda's question even though Amanda
seems no longer to want me to ask that
question but Amanda said doesn't that
disturb you doesn't it disturb me that I
don't have the free will that I think
that I have and it doesn't it doesn't
because where I feel good about my place
in the world does not come from this
misguided notion in my view again I say
my view I'm not trying to be dogmatic
about things you prove me wrong and I'll
change my perspective but nobody has but
I don't gain my sense of value and worth
from being able to triumph over the laws
of physics a game a sense of value and
worth from recognizing that unlike this
this glass of murky water that people
chime in whenever I Drake roll grain soy
milk unlike this this glass of tea this
cup of tea
I can do things that
are within my behavioral repertoire that
are not in the behavioral repertoire for
the cup of tea
the cup of tea just hangs out there and
no matter what I do to it at most it
moves or chimneys it shakes it spills or
breaks but that's the only kind of
behavior that the cup of tea can
undertake I because I'm so more fully
developed refined and organized in my
particulate arrangement compared to that
of the cup of tea can do so many more
things I can think feel reflect I can
puzzle about things I can work on the
equations of quantum and I can talk to
you right now I can respond to the
stimulus of your questions written down
in a chat bar that I'm seeing on a
screen the cup of tea can't do that I am
NOT freely choosing my responses I'm not
freely choosing the motion of my hands
I'm not freely choosing my actions but I
am thrilled by the fact that my range of
behavioral responses is so spectacularly
broad compared to the inanimate world so
my freedom is not freedom to triumph
over the mathematical laws of the
universe my freedom is to be released
from the bondage of limited behavioral
response that constrains the inanimate
world I have been released from that and
so have you
evolution has released us from that
bondage and that's where we should get a
sense of value from that's what we
should feel good about not trying thing
over mathematical walls okay so back to
maybe some some more concrete physics
stuff Brandon Wood says can you discuss
Eric Weinstein's geometric unity theory
and I can't
and I guess enough people ask me about
this theory that maybe I should spend a
little while immersing myself in it to
get a fuller sense of what it is I can
only speak secondhand and what I've
heard secondhand from people that I
trust is that there's not a whole lot to
this theory that could be wrong maybe
Eric Weinstein is the next Einstein or
the Ramanuja you know often left-field I
know he was a math major I think at
Harvard's I read something and and I
know that that his experience was less
than happy one at Harvard and felt that
there was a sort of old boys network
behind the scenes that was really
determining what papers get published
and what works are paid attention to and
I don't know whenever I hear that kind
of conspiracy theory behind the deep
state of mathematics and physics yeah
what can I say I just I don't see any
evidence for it I've been I've been in
the field in the thick of the field now
since you know call it from me when I
graduated with my PhD 1987 or something
so whatever 33 years you know I
published papers I referee papers I I
speak at conferences I organize God you
know and the only thing that matters to
me into the folks that I have spent
decades working with is the quality of
the ideas we are open to having our
ideas smashed to pieces and having the
new upstart come in and revolutionize
our understanding of things we love that
we don't suppress that we don't try to
somehow keep the status quo we love
changing our perspective based on
observation experiment deep mathematical
insight so I don't know I just get this
sinking feeling whenever there's
somebody who's making a statement about
the controlling forces in the world of
math and physics that are somehow
suppressing the new ideas from rising to
the top nothing in my experience
in my experience could be further from
the truth but who knows maybe I've had
blinders on I don't think so maybe I've
had blinders on for the last 35 years
and there's all this this dark stuff
happening just behind the closed doors
of each physics department but it seems
ludicrous to me and again I don't want
to put words into everybody's mouth if
that's not what Eric Weinstein or
anybody else is saying I could
completely be wrong but just let me
speak from my own perspective there's
nothing like that as far as I understand
okay
so fellas super says how to use a
physicist come up with new ideas well
you know the new ideas are few and far
between I have to say I'm gonna say new
ideas I mean really big new ideas mean
all of us come up with new ideas and
trying to solve whatever limited
research problem that were faced with
that a given moment in those little
moments of of creativity those little
moments of progress are what keep us
going
that's really exciting but the real big
ideas where do they come from cool I
don't know I mean I have only had a
handful a small handful maybe hand you
know as too many maybe three or four the
course of a lifetime that seemed to
really make a difference in in what
people work on and and the kinds of
things that really advance understanding
and usually it's a matter of a lot of
hard work you're beating your head
against the wall trying to solve a
problem and all of a sudden there is
just a new pattern that that you see
finally I mean I think that's what what
we are we as a species are these pattern
recognition machines and most of our
pattern recognition has been developed
over the course of evolutionary history
so that we can get the next meal we can
find mates we can build shelters we can
survive in a hostile environment and
some of us are the product of that long
lineage but are so enamored by pattern
in the external world that we develop
mathematical ideas to embrace the subtle
patterns
you don't need to survive the patterns
that have to do with the motion of the
planets patterns that have to do with
the motion of electrons and quarks and
we write down the walls of classical
mechanics the laws of quantum physics
and then we go further and we try to
find mathematical articulations of
patterns about things that we can't even
yet see the blending of quantum
mechanics and the general fear
relativity so we try to find patterns in
the patterns of the mathematics used to
describe the paddles that are out there
in the world and it's really a matter of
refining your sense of pattern to be
able to recognize when there's a new
configuration that puts together things
that we once thought to be separate and
that blending of things that we once
thought to be separate is really the
core of the creative process as a
scientist
all right so X do you think if Einstein
had known what we know now he'd be able
to finish his theory of everything ah I
don't think so III there was a time when
the deep questions were accessible to a
single brilliant mind and in the early
part of 20th century that mind was
Albert Einstein but there are many
people around Einstein who did a lot of
the groundwork that helped his own
thinking but you know in the general
theory of relativity it was largely the
genius of Einstein that was pushing his
radical ideas forward even against the
advice of others like Max Planck who
told Einstein stop it don't work on
gravity you're not gonna get to the
answer and if you do he even said no one
will believe the answer you come up with
these ideas are just too complicated
they're beyond the reach of our current
understanding of physics is what Planck
was saying but Einstein didn't listen to
that came up with the general theory of
relativity and again just to go to the
point that I mentioned before when he
put forward the general theory of
relativity people read the paper people
understood the paper people changed
their way of thinking about things
because of this
new insight no one tried to suppress
Einstein because the brilliance of his
ideas blazed through the dark corners of
reality and nobody could mistake them
for anything but deep progress in our
understanding of the world now you know
we would love that to happen with our
current understanding but I don't think
it's a single person job anymore
I think the issues at hand are so
significant and they're so distant from
observation and experiment and they
require such a broad range of
mathematical expertise that I think it's
a really a communal effort I mean who
knows maybe some new genius will come
along and that person single-handedly
will come up with the unified theory and
that will be it that's possible I guess
I just think it's I just think it's
unlikely all right so oh let's see what
do we have maybe I'll go back to some
YouTube question what do we have here
Wow some of these questions I've already
dealt with
I don't know I'm not finding anything
there that really fires me up so i'ma go
back to the YouTube feed over here Kevin
asks will the strings of string theory
be made of individual constituents that
are you know smaller still and Kevin I
don't I don't know certainly if I was to
answer based on historical precedent it
is the case that every time we introduce
some new fundamental ingredient new new
entity there's something further inside
right and you get down to molecules
molecules are made of atoms as you know
atoms got the central nucleus protons
and neutrons you got the electron cloud
and then even you go inside protons and
neutrons and you learn back in the 1960s
that they have quarks inside of them now
if the idea of string theory is true big
f but for the purposes of this question
imagine string theory is true if you go
inside quarks or electrons and you find
something else is vibrating filament is
at the end of the story or could it be
that even if that is true as Kevin asks
there's a finer entity inside of strings
themselves and people have certainly
studied the possibility that there are
finer entities that make up the strings
of string theory and those are very
interesting studies but even though
studies posit an ingredient like d0
particles and various objects that come
out of the mathematical description of
string theory so you could just
translate your question to those
ingredients whatever they might be and
say are they the end of the line
so so the the overall question they're
asking Kevin is will we ever get to a
point when we've identified ingredients
that we can say that's it nothing finer
to be found that journey is over and I
do believe that we could get to that
point i do not think by any means that
it's necessarily the case that as we go
deeper and deeper and deeper we will
always find more and more new stuff the
chapter that has been searching for the
deepest reductionist understanding
a physical law is a story that may come
to an end
have we reached the end yet with string
theory I don't even know if string
theory is right and even if it is right
there's nothing to say that we've
necessarily reached the reductionist end
but speaking more generally I do think
that reductionism is not a infinite
progression necessarily it is something
that could indeed come to an end all
right other questions to ask um well
actually here's a question that I that's
not in the Twitter feed but a friend of
mine asked it to me just the other day
friend of mine named Ken vine burg
brilliant architect maybe he's even
listening right now I have no idea but
uh yeah he designed even the space that
I'm in right now my apartment in New
York sent some strange since I live in
the vision of this individual Ken by
Barry since he designed all these spaces
that I spent like 80% of my life and he
asked me to follow me because she says
look in these live sessions he says you
always say the truth you never say
anything that's incorrect but he said
sometimes he feels that I allow you
folks who are talking to me to have the
impression that certain weird qualities
of the world might be true when in
reality I fully anticipate that they're
not true French and so sometimes people
that ask about quantum entanglement may
be minds can be intended no there's some
people I think last time asked about the
multiverse and and whether versus of us
might exist in those other universes and
that might give us some means of
immortality that we would carry on in
the other universes and and and my view
of these far-out sounding ideas is this
the most important thing that I can do
in these kinds of conversations is give
you insight into what modern physics
says about the objective workings of the
world the stuff that's out there that is
amenable to third party objective
measurement observation we can all go
out there and measure it and check it at
least in principle and that's what
physics is about what physics is not
particularly good at
is the reverse journey not into the
outer world but into the inner world the
inner world of conscious experience we
spoke about freewill the inner world of
spiritual exploration trying to
understand your place in the grand
cosmic order trying to understand the
kind of responses that we human beings
have to the things in the world the kind
of anxieties that we might have the
kinds of goals achievements that we
might seek out in the wider world and
that's not the place where physics gives
us particular insights so I'm quite open
when people are thinking about that
journey in language or in ideas that are
distinct from the ideas that I know to
be true in describing the external world
well I let you get away with wild
sounding ideas like quantum entanglement
means our brains may be entangled or
that ESP might originate incontinent
absolutely not that's utter nonsense but
am i sympathetic to the notion that in
trying to deal with our own mortality we
may tell ourselves stories that are
incompatible with the external world and
we may even know that yet we're willing
to allow those stories to inform the way
we feel about our lives in the wider
world I am sympathetic to that I mean
I've said on occasion I'll say it here
too I don't I don't really care you know
on occasion I do things like imagine I'm
talking to my father who's been dead for
over thirty years
I imagine sometimes that he's actually
even watching or enjoying some of the
things that are happening some of the
things that I'm doing and so forth do I
literally believe that is that
compatible with my understanding of how
the physical universe works
absolutely not that's done eNOS
craziness if you are imagining that it's
actually an object of quality of the
external world but as an internal coping
mechanism as something that allows me to
have a richer inner life that I find
pleasing does it make sense from that
perspective it does so as long as you or
I or anybody is able to distinguish
between the true objective qualities of
the world
the things that are really out there and
I don't care what it is from quantum
mechanics to climate change okay
these are unassailable things that are
happening in the external world if you
can distinguish that between the things
that you may use to have your own
existence be more comfortable or make
sense to you or be richer if you can
distinguish between the two then allow
your inner world to do whatever your
creative imagination leads you to and
that to me is a perfectly fine way of
existing in the world okay back to some
perhaps more physics see stuff azam
Nayeem asks sir what is the speed of
gravity what is the speed of gravity
answer to that question is the speed of
gravity is equal to 671 million miles
per hour 300 million meters per second
it is equal to the speed of light so one
of the deep insights and Einstein's
general theory of relativity is that
gravity does not travel instantaneously
from one point to another in Isaac
Newton's description of gravity gravity
is an instantaneous force right when you
look at Newton's equation F equals G m1
m2 over R squared there is no time in
that equation which means that if you
were to change the value of one of two
masses maybe this is the earth and this
is the Sun if you were to change the
mass of the Sun then immediately in that
equation the value of the force would
differ if you cut the mass of the Sun in
half then according to that equation F
equals G m1 m2 over R squared the force
that the earth would experience would be
cut down by a factor of two immediately
there's no time delay in Newton's
equation and Einstein comes along and
says that's not right that can't work
that would allow influences that can
carry information to travel at a speed
that's bigger than the speed of light
he believes that wasn't possible so in
the general theory of relativity he
fixes this problem with Newton's theory
and
in this description gravity is
transmitted by warps and curves rippling
through the fabric of space-time and
those ripples travel at the speed of
light and therefore the speed of light
and the speed of gravity are one and the
same thing this fixes the problem with
Newton's version of gravity and give us
our deepest understanding of the force
of gravity and that actually reminds me
of another question I saw in the scroll
I wish I could credit the person who
asked it but there was a question I know
about 20 minutes ago about entanglement
and entanglement violating the limit on
the speed of light right doesn't mean if
you do you imagine as we discussed you
got these sort of these particles that
are spinning up and spinning down and
the idea was each is a 50-50 mixture you
measure one and it makes the distant
particles snap out of the quantum hey as
much as the initial particle snaps out
of the haze and that would seem to be an
instantaneous influence you do a
measurement over here and it
instantaneously affects the particle
over here that would seem to violate the
limit set by the speed of light and I
totally get that intuition but when you
look more closely the speed limit set by
the speed of light survives barely
because in a sense what Einstein's limit
on the speed of anything through space
was delineating is a limit on how fast
any kind of influence that carries
information can travel one point in the
universe to another right right now I am
communicating information to you right
I'm not even talking about the content
of what I'm saying I however right now
I'm causing your eardrums to vibrate and
it's of course not an instantaneous
signal it's vibrating from my vocal
cords through my mouth into the
microphones in this room through the
internet and into your ears right but
the idea is that if I try to communicate
to you using quantum entanglement not
that standard approach of sending a
sound wave
I would fail why me think about it here
you got these two distant particles
they're each in a 50/50 mixture and up
and down if I'm over here and want to
send a message over there what I want to
do is say hey if the particles say winds
up spinning down then sell Amazon stock
let's say that's the information I want
to send to you but here's the thing I
can't control whether this one is going
to be up or down upon measurement and
therefore if this one turned out down
this one would be up so I wouldn't be
sending you the information that I want
the point is the outcome is random it's
just at both of these locations the
random results are correlated but I
can't control the outcome at one place
or another and therefore I can't control
the information therefore I can't send
information therefore this influence
however spooky and odd it may seem does
not carry information from place to
place
and in that sense does not violate this
way of framing Einstein's dictum that
nothing in the sense of no information
you travel faster than the speed of
light but yes it is a it is a close call
and not everybody agrees with the
description I've given here so that's
the that's the other side of the story -
and if I'm more detail on that you can
look at my book fabric of the cosmos one
of the chapters on entanglement maybe
it's chapter 6 source and I can't
remember now I go through the various
ways in which people have responded to
the possibility that entanglement might
violate speed of light limit ok ok ok
let's see what else we have here
darn that was a hurry Oh global digital
direct subsidiary democracy asks me if
mathematics is so almighty and lawful
why does it have the holes that girdle
exposed so so yeah it's interesting
question it's not the girdle exposed
holes in mathematics
what girdle did was to establish the
limits of the kinds of things that
mathematics is able to prove
and girdle establish that there can be
true statements within a given
mathematical formalism that lie beyond
the reach of that formal system that
could not be proved true within the
axioms of that system itself this is a
shocking result it's a surprising result
it's not a hole in mathematics it is an
advance in our understanding of the
kinds of issues that mathematical
analysis is able to encapsulate now
perhaps what you're asking
person from global digital direct
subsidiary democracy is what if the
physical universe has a gird Delian like
quality and there are aspects of the
unfolding of reality that are beyond the
reach of mathematical description and
that that is a subtle question I don't
think that is the case you might say
well hey if it's true for mathematics
and mathematics are the underlying laws
of physics so aren't you stuck no
because girl proved his theorem within a
certain set of assumptions and those
assumptions may not hold true for the
mathematical system that truly describes
the fundamental laws of physics so I
mean there's one fun little example of
that
you know girdles using the standard
logic that I think we all have an
intuition about but there are other
versions of logic I'm not saying this is
how the world works but just as a consid
existence proof there kinds of logic
that are called para consistent logics
in which a statement and its negation
can actually both be true but you can't
concatenate them in a manner that allow
you to prove that any thing is true and
so there are these kinds of logics and
in those logical systems girdle's ideas
don't actually follow so if it were the
case for instance just again as an
existent argument then one of the other
kinds of logics was actually relevant to
the true mathematics underlying physical
law then girl since I wouldn't even
apply so I'm not saying that that's the
answer but I'm saying it's far too quick
to say that once girl approved the
incompleteness theorem in mathematics in
physics is necessary thing complete
doesn't follow doesn't necessarily work
that way okay louia likes fire ask is
there an explanation for wave particle
duality and that's basically saying is
there an explanation for quantum
mechanics why the world is quantum
mechanical and I I don't really have an
explanation I don't think anybody does
it could have been the case that our
world was governed by classical laws the
ones that Isaac Newton gave us and that
could have been it it could have been
that F equals MA with various choices
for F was it and this law written down
in the late 1600s would have been the
end of the story and it just so happens
that it's not it it just so happens that
as we dug deeper we realize that there
are limitations to the applicability of
Newton's ideas and that forced us to
develop these quantum ideas in which as
Lowell likes fire asks there is this
wave nature of matter and this particle
nature of matter but logically speaking
could I imagine a universe in which
there wasn't wave particle duality I can
imagine it is it somehow deeply
inconsistent maybe and maybe therefore
the answer to your question is
consistency alone somehow demands that
quantum mechanics is part of the story
and therefore wave particle duality is
part of the story I I don't know
but what I do know is if you allow for
wave particle duality and if you write
down the equations that describe it and
if you use those equations to try to say
things about the external world the
predictions emerging from those
equations are spot on accurate and so
the way we physicists tend to look at it
is nature demands that we use a quantum
mechanical description in order to have
an accurate explanation of what's
happening in the external world but it's
hard for us to say that it had to be
that way it's hard for us to say that
there is some deeper explanation for why
the world is quantum mechanical
all right what else do we have here
Raja asks hi hi what are your thoughts
on the true nature of space on the basis
of quantum entanglement sort of in the
holographic projection ideas that have
emerged from people like Gerard a tuft
and Lenny Susskind and look Raja I think
that's that is the deep question I don't
know the answer to it in the Newtonian
description you had space it just was
the arena
static arena in which events take place
you had time which was this cosmic clock
ticking forward second after second the
same for everybody Einstein comes along
a few hundred years later changes that
he says no no no space is not just a
stage space warps and curves in response
to the stuff within the universe and
therefore space is part of the
cosmological unfolding and time is as
well and rights now new equations
quantum mechanics comes along and
describes this quality of entanglement
or distant particles act as though they
are right next to each other and then
string theoretic ideas come along and
take that progression even further
envisioning that the world around us is
nothing but a holographic projection of
laws and processes taking place on some
distant two-dimensional surface that
surrounds us much as a two-dimensional
piece of plastic when illuminated
correctly yields a realistic
three-dimensional image we would be the
three-dimensional image emerging from
the laws of physics projecting through
this holographic surface that surrounds
us and yes are these ideas
revolutionising or seeding a revolution
and their understanding of space and
time absolutely and and that
understanding is currently underway
there are a lot of folks who are trying
to understand how the fabric of space
perhaps is actually stitched together by
the threads of quantum entanglement
wonderfully exciting idea we've done
program
at the World Science Festival you should
check out a program that I'm moderated
with mark Vaughn roms doc and other
leaders in the field I can't remember
the name of the program off the top of
my head but maybe we'll link it you can
take a look at that but it's an
unfinished story and so I don't know the
answer to how to really think about
space and time in light of these recent
developments but as I mentioned I'm
about 20 minutes ago in answer to
another question I think the big
revolution will happen for a job when we
finally do have the full answer to the
insightful question that you asked
earnest asks do you think the Higgs
boson contributes to the mass of
space-time I don't think it does I know
it does so when we talk about the mass
energy that is permeating space we need
to include every source and one such
source is this field permeating space
called the Higgs field that Higgs field
that sort of cosmic molasses not the
best metaphor but not a bad one for
having in mind what the Higgs does this
Higgs field has energy and that energy
translates into if you will an
equivalent amount of mass and when we
map out the totality of the mass energy
that is filling the universe the Higgs
is one such contribution so it's not a
dominant contribution the dark energy
which perhaps is a Higgs like field is a
much more significant component of the
mass energy of the universe something
like 68 percent of the mass energy of
the universe is contained in this
uniform field filling space called the
dark energy but the Higgs is an
analogous contribution is just much
smaller okay what do we have here
well Greg Gutfeld asks a question but I
I don't know I'm not so into describing
that question so I'm gonna skip your
question Greg clean it up next time
buddy if you will what else do we have
here
let's see
Mohammed asks do you believe in the
simulation hypothesis this is a good
question that kind of comes back to the
issue that my friend Ken Feinberg raised
do I allow for the simulation hypothesis
it's a wild crazy sounding idea right
that we right now might be within some
futuristic supercomputer simulating
beings like ourselves and we think that
we are consciously out in the real world
when in actuality we are just motions of
electrons coursing through a futuristic
circuit in some powerful supercomputer
do I allow for that possibility I do
allow for that possibility do I think
it's likely to be the case I don't even
know how to describe likely here but if
I just go with my gut sensation I'd say
no I think this world is real I think
that's the case now I have to admit if
it's a good enough simulation the
simulator would have been able to make
me think that it's real and indeed I
think as I mentioned in one of these
sessions an Oxford philosopher Nick
Bostrom makes an argument that if we can
ever create simulated worlds in
supercomputers they may be a dime a
dozen it may be very inexpensive to buy
one of those computers in the future and
everybody is firing up their own
universe simulation creating a huge
range of simulated conscious beings and
therefore the number of simulated
conscious beings compared the number of
real conscious beings would be enormous
there'd be many more beings in a
computer than they would be walking
around in the real world and therefore
if you ask yourself are you real or
simulated the odds would seem to suggest
that you are simulated so you know it is
a crazy wild sounding ideas and it is
kind of crazy
it's worth taking seriously because it
allows us to reframe certain kinds of
questions in a way that you may or may
not find useful but if you ask me do I
walk around the world truly imagining
that there is some simulate or outside
of this universe that has set up this
computer system that we are inhabiting
no I don't really think that way but I
do find it useful for instance you know
when people talk about the existence of
a god almost always they think about
that in the context of a supernatural
being a being that stands outside the
bounds of physical law but the nice
thing about this simulated version of
having a creator is that creator could
well be subject to the physical laws in
the real world and therefore that kid
maybe it's a kid no garage and a
futuristic garage they've just got a
supercomputer for Christmas and is fired
up that supercomputer and here we are
talking about the possibility that we
are simulated beings and we are doing
this in that kids simulation that kid
would be our Creator by definition but
there'd be nothing supernatural I don't
think that's really the reality but I
like the idea for giving me and others a
way of thinking about a world that has a
creator that need not be simulated that
can be subject to physical law all right
so we're coming up on an hour here I
don't know maybe I'll do one one more
here if I can find one that's kind of
cool to do oh come on I had one and then
it's Grove I again I guess I can't have
my thing on this
[Music]
yes so so Mario asks from Chile an
interesting question
Reza green what would the result of
simultaneously measuring the properties
of two entangled particles separated by
a meaningful distance in the same frame
of reference be and and and the answer
to that and I understand why you're
asking that question saying look you
know if I always talk about you measure
this one it affects this one or you
measure this one it affects that one and
it makes it sound as though you couldn't
sort of measure them both together there
might be sort of a clash where this one
wants to affect this one and this one
wants to affect that one and what what
would happen would it fall apart would
with the physical process somehow be
inconsistent and the answer is look it's
simply the case that these two particles
are perfectly correlated if the quantum
state is set up correctly so you know if
you were to measure this one and this
one simultaneously this one up that one
down you would get the consistent
results that they are anti-correlated
or the result would happen so in that
particular case the language of sort of
which affected which would be difficult
to apply in that particular case but
nevertheless the result would be
perfectly consistent with the quantum
mechanical prediction which is when this
is up that's down when this is up that's
that and vice-versa
so there really wouldn't be anything
particularly striking there moreover and
I don't mean to conflict complicate
things unnecessarily if somebody was in
a different frame of reference and I
believe that Mario understands this
based on the framing of the question if
somebody was in a different frame of
reference watching these two
simultaneous measurements taking place
in save this frame of reference from
their perspective their notion of
simultaneity would be different from the
simultaneity in this frame and therefore
they would say that one person measured
first in the other second and so their
description would indeed involve say
this particle B measure detecting that
one this product will be measured fun
depending on how they are moving and so
from that perspective even if those
measurements are simultaneous in one
frame they're not simultaneous in
another and so the description that I
gave would be applicable
and that other frame alright so so what
should I do one more before we get out
of here um Victor I'll give you the
final question Victor Victor asks what
do you think about quantum Darwinism and
it depends exactly what you mean by
quantum Darwinism it's certainly case of
quantum mechanics applies to everything
it applies to the particles that make up
life it applies to the particles in a
block of American cheese it applies to
the particles making up this murky Earl
Grey tea that I will no longer touch
because it's like spoil by now so
quantum mechanics is at work in
everything and therefore it's certainly
involved in the underlying physical
processes behind Darwinian evolution but
it goes beyond that I'm not sure this is
what you're asking Victor but I'll
finish with this following thought most
of us when we learned about Darwinian
evolution and natural selection we've
learned about it in the context of how
species yield ever wider range of
species in the future on the Origin of
Species is the context in which Darwin
described this idea and what we've
learned in decades in a century sense is
that the Darwinian notion of natural
selection is much more general you don't
need living systems even if you have
molecules okay molecules that learn the
trick of making copies of themselves and
it's it's a beautiful trick it's it's a
trick that molecules can learn they can
learn to drag in to their environment
the very kinds of particles out of which
they are constituted and the initial
molecule can serve as a template for
building a copy of itself it's like DNA
but DNA needs the structure of life so
imagine a kind of DNA like molecule but
without all of the architecture of life
already in existence and once molecules
learn how to replicate then you have a
notion of natural selection because
those molecules that can replicate
faster and more stable manner
in a more efficient manner are going to
win out they're gonna grab in more and
more of the natural resources the
particles the environment create more
and more copies of themselves so they
will dominate the molecular demographics
it's a kind of chemical combat is how I
describe it in in the new book that I
came out with a couple months of them
until the end of time you can read more
about it there but the point is that you
have natural selection at the level of
molecules because when a mutation
happens if that mutation allows that
molecule to do an even better job at
making copies of itself it will beat out
its parent and it will then dominate the
molecular demographics so all of these
processes ultimately rely on quantum
mechanics in quantum physics there is a
notion of Darwinian natural selection at
the level of particles where quantum
mechanics really show their true colors
true true colors but nothing about this
is fundamentally quantum mechanical it's
just the way the universe evolves and
therefore I wouldn't want to inject too
much of quantum thinking as at the
essence of Darwinian natural selection
acting itself out on molecules but
nevertheless yes I do agree that quantum
mechanics is part of that story at the
most basic level of the ingredients and
the laws that govern how those
ingredients behave all right so we're at
4:07 I'm pretty tuckered out I hope you
enjoyed this live session and I
anticipate picking up your daily
equation with a new episode on Monday
let me just quickly note as you may have
noticed if you're following the series
on occasion there's too much going on
for me to get a new episode out on a
given day I'll pologize now at the
outset when that happens but I'll always
try to give like a little message and
suggest other videos that I have been
involved with that you might enjoy
watching and hopefully that's a
reasonable substitute in those days but
it will keep going again I don't know
how long we're gonna keep your daily
equation going I've been having fun
doing it
I feel like some of the episodes have
been getting more and more technical so
maybe that needs to be scaled back and
try to find it maybe she let me know
actually do you want things to be less
technical
daily equation more of the ideas and
less of the mass or do you like more of
the math at the level say that I've been
doing in the last few episode I really
be interested to hear your views on that
but next week I think I'm gonna do a
little bit more quantum mechanics
maybe Bell's Theorem if I can work up
the courage to try to do that
maybe the Fineman pact integral the
basic idea there and then I'll turn to I
think general relativity the basic idea
of metrics and curvature apply that to
cosmology understand the big bang at the
level of Einstein's equations and then
who knows maybe we'll be done or maybe
we'll carry on from there I'm gonna
leave that open okay anyway it's been a
fun hour and nine minutes to spend with
you this Friday afternoon enjoy the rest
of your weekend looking forward to
catching up with you in a new session on
Monday of your daily equation take care